Punxsutawney Phil ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
Mr President we have a scroll we have a
scroll
hear ye hear ye
now on this February 2nd Punxsutawney
Phil The Seer of Sears was awakened from
his wintry nap at dawn on Gobbler's Knob
Phil looked to the skies and then
speaking in groundhogies directed this
President Uncle to the proper scroll
which reads
I see the morning has brought the finest
people
I see their bravery and spirit
the time has come I can feel it the
excitement I can hear it
I see the folks with gray in their hair
and I see the kids all young and scrawny
their eyes and cheeks a glow from the
cold clean air of sweet Punxsutawney
I see that everyone knows their part
and I am merely the sage
but above all else I see a shadow on my
stage and so no matter how you measure
it's six more weeks of winter weather
[Applause]